Both his winning 2016 campaign
and his 2020 defeat.
The former president
enjoyed strong support obviously
from white evangelical voters.
77% in 2016
according to a Pew Research Center
84% in 2020 with in mind
Gary Tuchman visited a Baptist church
in Virginia
where the pastor seemed
to buck that trend
during the last election.
And his congregation did not like it
at the Stuart Street Baptist Church
in Virginia Shenandoah Valley.
Good morning
everyone and
good to see you
all here in worship together
this Sunday services
led by a pastor
who took the place of this pastor.
I don't want to start controversy
Apparently, God does
and I'm just the messenger
taking his place
after this outdoor
sermon during the worst of the COVID
pandemic,
just a few months before the 2020
presidential election,
why will we not finally admit that we
have put
a liar in our White House?
Why will we not finally admit
that that is Antichrist?
And William Cobb would have been
the spiritual leader of this evangelical
Southern Baptist Church for 14 years,
wasn't anywhere near done
talking about then-President
Donald Trump.
18,000 fact check lies.
1100 days is more than just unacceptable.
It is more than just sin.
It is more than just wrong.
It is demonic.
And then Kopp added this,
and you can't deny it
because Jesus says it.
And if you choose to deny that,
then you choose to deny Jesus
You can't have it both ways.
You can't support the lie
and claim the truth.
You can't support the Antichrist
and support the crimes.
This is William Kopp
and his wife, Carol, today
after you made this sermon.
What happened to you? I was fired.
I knew when I heard it
that we would not be
staying at the church.
I want to say it was a friend.
Jim Brooks is a deacon at the church.
The thing that got me
was at the very end.
Pastor Cop said
that if you voted for John Trump,
you are not a Christian.
That was the biggest thing for me.
Within 48 hours,
William Cobb says the church leaders,
including Deacon Brooks,
asked for his resignation.
Is what you're saying?
Do you believe that
people cannot be good Christians
or thinking Christians
if they support Donald Trump?
That's a real tough one.
And
probably that's exactly what I'm saying.
William
Cobb says his sermon criticized
other political
and religious leaders, too,
and contends
it was not a political speech,
but a moral one.
Sermons in the evangelical churches
combining politics, morals
and faith are far from rare.
Two days before the 2020 election.
Listen to this pastor in Maine.
We have an election on Tuesday.
I pray God's mercy grant US
President Donald Trump victory.
I don't have a problem
standing in front of you
in the same zone.
And four days after Election Day,
this Texas pastor
referring to the so-called
stolen election,
expose our wickedness intended to steal,
to kill
and destroy
the electoral process
in these battleground states.
Now let's pray.
According to surveys
from the Pew Research Center.
It appears there's a strong association
between Trump's political movement
and the evangelical religious label.
The research
from last year
further indicates
that among all white adults
who participated in
both the 20,
16 and 2020 surveys
25% described themselves as Born-Again
or evangelical Protestants in 2016.
29% described themselves this way in
20, 27 Corinthians five.
21.
The current pastor of the Stuarts
Draft Church,
Billy Coffee,
who talked to us off
camera, says he loved Pastor Carl,
but told us many congregants
were upset
and hurt by what he said
and would leave if Pastor Kopp did not.
So it was a matter of saving the church
rather than saving the pastor.
The new pastor telling us
when you mix religion and politics,
it won't make religion better.
So William and Carol Cupp
have now moved to North Carolina
and have joined a Presbyterian church
where he will occasionally fill in
for pastoral duties.
What do you think
the Lord thinks of what you said
in your sermon that day?
Well done. My good and faithful servant
Gary Do.
William Cupp indicated
if he had any misgivings about
how he handled the situation
Well, Anderson,
I did talk to William Kopp about that.
Obviously,
his life has changed a great deal,
but he says he's comfortable
with what he did
and he believes what he said in
his sermon is quote, biblically supported
Anderson.
Gary Tuchman, appreciate it. Thanks.